[Musique]
vous goûterez un bonjour bonjour alors
candidat donc pour les élections
municipales et communautaires au carbet
ce n'est pas votre première candidature
vous vous étiez déjà présenté en 2008 et
en 2014 pourquoi vouloir tenter une
troisième fois
parce que le contexte est différent
notamment de 2014 où on avait
effectivement fait des primaires au
premier tour mille 60 voix pour les
trois candidats de l'opposition et 1013
droit pour le maire sortant jean claude
et qu'en ville malheureusement nous
n'avons pas pu nous accorder au deuxième
tour sur la candidature unique tel que
c'était prévu donc on a sacrifié la
victoire d'écart des siens sur l'hôtel
je dirais des égouts et d appétit
débordant et là les conditions vous
paraissent plus favorable pour 2020 les
conditions pour 2020 sont différentes
puisque nous allons à cette élection
avec la ferme intention de gagner dès le
premier tour parce que nous pensons
aujourd'hui que effectivement les carbis
y ont appris à me connaître ils ont
appris à travailler avec moi à me
solliciter dans de multiples de
multiples raisons ils ont appris à
m'apprécier beaucoup d'entre eux m'ont
témoignée m'ont confié leur admiration
devant mon engagement ma détermination
et surtout l'expérience des hommes et
des femmes qui composent notre liste
alors parlez parlez nous ont justement
monsieur cas où il présentait un peu
votre justement je ne crois pas en
l'homme providentiel et on écoute la
litanie de candidats qui passent à votre
émission
je ne crois certainement pas en l'homme
providentiel mais je crois aux vertus du
travail collectif car c'est ensemble
solidairement que nous parviendrons
effectivement à relever les grands
enjeux et quand je dis ça c'est pour le
territoire martinique comme vous la
commune du carbet et les autres communes
donc nous avons une liste de femmes et
d'hommes expérimentés et qui sont
compétents et nous avons fait ce choix
pour pouvoir effectivement relever un
triple contrat ce contrat c'est un
contrat d'objectif municipal bien sûr le
contrat citoyen parce qu'il faut voir la
politique autrement qu'en 2014
par exemple on comptera 6 3 hier pour
améliorer la qualité du service public
l'écoutent et l'accompagnement des
administrés c'est fondamental et ça va
très loin
ce contrat citoyen alors avec des
procédures de vous allez pouvoir
développer
puisque je vais vous poser des questions
et puis nous avons bien sûr vous pensez
bien à temps leur président martin
l'écologie nous avons un contrat
écologique parce qu'il ya de grands
défis à relever
du point de vue écologique et défis
économiques et sociales parce qu'il faut
absolument que l'on arrive à faire
cesser à lutter contre l'exode rural que
l'on a en ce moment
et non vous parlez de liste citoyenne
louis blouin ça veut dire que vous
n'avez ni investiture ni soutien de
quiconque d'un quelconque parti ou d'une
quelconque personnalité politique de
notre échiquier
nous avons fait un choix le choix c'est
la confiance en la population du carbet
en sa capacité de résilience confiance
en l'expérience et la compétence des
hommes et des femmes qui composent la
lys et puis c'est un choix qui est
pleinement assumée pour éviter que l'on
vienne comme ça s'est vu récemment le 2
février à une brochette d'élus du ppm
venu pour effectivement nous servir des
propos laudateurs et des superlatifs
pour vanter les mérites de maire sortant
que l'on connaît déjà et dont on voit le
résultat sa politique vous voulez
critiquer vivement sur
son action notamment chez nature je ne
critique pas nous faisons un constat est
le constat tous les administrés le font
donc il n'ya pas lieu de s'éterniser sur
les insuffisances ce monsieur est qu'en
ville où ces carences la population le
voit donc je ne le ferai pas il n'y a
pas quelque chose d'emblématique
justement de sa manière de jouer
c'est un constat de carence généralisé
tant dans la gestion municipale avec un
taux de réalisation de travaux qui on le
constate la commune est à l'arrêt sur la
réalisation des travaux
mais suite au niveau du budget un taux
d'investissement dans la commune qui est
excessivement faibles donc tout ce que
nous avons tous les éducateurs soient
budgétaire soit le carbone se
développent ne s'est pas développée ces
derniers temps pour selon vous tout
dépend ce que vous mettez dans le
développement
nous ne n'avons pas la même définition
du développement par contre il ya des
priorités et nous avons défini dix
priorités pour voir sortir le carbet
vous de cette situation pourrait pas
développer les dix priorités de la
trouver en citer deux ou trois notamment
les plus importante à vos yeux oui les
juges urgente des plus urgentes mais je
faisais dit que nous avons trois
objectifs à partir d'un contrat
d'objectifs municipal pour le carbet
poule mandature de 6 ans je faisais
parler du contrat citoyen mais il nous
avons un contrat écologique pour
préserver et valoriser notre patrimoine
naturel nos paysages extraordinaires
nous 7 km de plage au carbet et pour
lutter contre les effets du
réchauffement climatique et surtout on
veut améliorer la gestion des déchets et
améliorer la gestion de l'eau il n'est
pas normal c'est une compétence de cap
nord à la communauté d'agglo il n'est
pas normal qu'aujourd'hui que les élus
ne se penche pas sur ce problème de
l'eau nous avons l'eau la plus chère de
france et de l'outre-mer il est temps
qu'on se retrousse les manches et qu'on
prenne à bras le corps le dossier d'une
gestion publique de l'eau que les
mastodontes de l'eau ne viennent pas se
sucrer sur le dos des usagers
nous avons également une volonté de
faire du carbet la capitale des
synergies renouvelables en criant les
conditions pour que les entreprises dans
une zone d'activité économique et
artisanal puisse venir s'implanter
entreprise de d'énergie renouvelable
également entreprises du numérique
dernière question avez vous une ambition
quelconque pour quatre morts est-ce que
vous même si vous êtes élu vous irez
siéger ou pouvez aussi désigner des
colistiers mais enfin voilà est-ce que
vous vous avez l'intention de prendre
une part importante dans les affaires
communautaires
je vous ai dit que je ne crois pas à
l'homme providentiel donc nous environ
les élus compétents à cattenom et ce
soir ce sera pas louis boutrin nous
avons un contrat avec la population et
c'est sur ce contrat que nous allons
nous pencher bien sûr en partenariat
avec cap nord en partenariat avec la
cité m et surtout ce que les élus locaux
généralement ne savent pas comment faire
pour utiliser les fonds européens
le fait d abu les entreprises le fait
bien pour effectivement les pêcheurs le
feader pour les agriculteurs et le fser
pour les entreprises vous avez le
demande d'emploi vous avez bien compris
que ça nécessite alain froide dans ce
sens est terminé et ça nécessite
également de l'expérience et nous
mettrons nos expériences et nos
compétences au service de la ville du
carbet et les quarts bishu mais s'y
empilent méchant
merci louis boutrin qui était dans sa
aux cadets municipal spécial municipal
donc à la réalisation paul-eric tout ça
[Musique]